Right.
All right.
There is a ton.
I have to talk to you guys about this
week.
As you probably know,
I was in Israel last week where I was
invited to speak at a video conference.
The remainder of the week was spent
wandering the streets talking to people
about peace and eating ridiculous
amounts of Hummus.
Spending most of my time in Tel Aviv,
I saw people have pretty much every
race,
color,
religion,
ethnicity and nationality,
living side by side.
I heard Hebrew,
Arabic,
English,
French,
Spanish,
Japanese,
German,
and several other languages being spoken
simultaneously in restaurants in cafes.
I saw a coexistence in a part of the
world that has very little of it.
I also spent a day in Jerusalem.
If you saw the video that we posted a
couple of days ago.
I tried to show how close these
religious sites are and give a little
context to an extremely small yet
complex city walking through the old
city of Jerusalem.
I explored the Jewish and Christian
quarters and stop for falafel and the
Arab quarter.
I felt it was important not just to talk
about these places as we do,
but actually to live them as well.
I exited the Old City at the Damascus
Gate where literally a day before a Jew
had been stabbed.
While there was no doubt the
neighborhood was tense,
there was also a feeling that this was
life.
Life goes on.
Unfortunately.
I heard about the San Bernardino
terrorist attacks while on the beach in
Israel.
I can't really explain to you guys how
incredibly surreal it was to be so far
away from something so horrific
happening 60 miles away from where I
live while I was 7,600
miles away from home.
Adding to the surreal feeling was that I
was in the Epi center of a country that
deals with terrorism in some form or
another pretty much every day.
Suddenly I had people asking me what it
was like to be in America with all our
mass shootings.
The world felt completely flipped on its
head.
On the 14 hour plane ride back to Los
Angeles,
I read what's left by my guest this
week.
Nicole and nick is a writer for time.
Spectator,
the observer and standpoint,
his first book,
what's left is an absolute must read if
you dig what we do here though,
what's left was written in 2017.
Nick absolutely nails so much of the
lunacy we've been talking about on the
left these days from their dishonest
tactics of lying about opponents' views
to aligning themselves with people who
are just as easily have them killed.
He goes on a journey through history to
show how the far left has so often
strengthened the very ideas that they
purport to be against.
There were so many passages of the book
that I felt like could have been written
today,
that it was almost like reading
something from the future.
He nailed the regressive left before the
term was even out there.
Speaking of the regressives,
you didn't think I was going to get
through a show without mentioning them
data?
Yeah.
Not gonna happen.
Uh,
one of the issues I've called them out
on consistently is that if they don't
stop smearing,
the liberals willing to talk about
Islamic extremism,
that they're going to hand our future to
the far right.
We're seeing this right this very second
across Europe as far right parties are
winning elections and gaining in the
polls from France to Belgium to Sweden
and more.
This is clearly coming to the American
shores,
right,
too.
As Donald trump just this week called
for denying Muslims entry into the
United States.
Obviously this is idiotic over the top
and ridiculous,
but it can only exist in a climate where
fear of real discussion has been
stifled.
If we aren't afraid of talking about
Islamism,
especially the difference between people
and doctrine,
then we can finally have an honest
conversation about refugees,
immigration and everything else,
but if we do,
as the regressives are doing this very
second by making no distinction between
people who are trying to talk about
serious issues versus people who trade
on fear,
then we help the real xenophobes and
silence the reformers.
Even as a kid,
I always loved John f Kennedy's famous
quote.
We have nothing to fear but fear itself.
It's lofty and big,
but it hits something that is extremely
human.
Sometimes fear and things is scarier
than the actual thing itself.
That's not to say that radical Islam is
scary,
but we also feed that fear if we don't
deal with it honestly,
now that we live in a time when people
are incredibly fearful and much of it is
with good reason,
as we've seen the spread of an evil
ideology with no signs of letting up,
that doesn't mean we have to be afraid
to speak out against it or silence those
who dare to do so.
Actually,
of course it means the exact opposite.
Fear is what the regressives and the far
right are both going to use to splinter
us against each other so they can gain
power.
The world is in a strange,
fearful moment,
right?
This very second,
we can either give into our worst
impulses or try to be better.
I'm pretty sure you guys know which side
I'm going to choose.
As we sat in a packed restaurant in Tel
Aviv,
I asked a friend how he feels about all
the stabbings without missing a beat.
He said,
we have to keep living.
We have no choice.
I think we could all use a little of
that spirit right now.
Let's not give into fear fed to us by
terrorists or fear fed to us by
politicians.
Let's keep fighting because if we don't
choice is exactly what we're going to
give up.
I guess this week is a writer for the
Observer,
the spectator time and standpoint.
He's authored two books.
You can't read this book and what's
left.
I just read what's left and I'm thrilled
to have him here.
Nicole,
and welcome to the show mark.
So Nick,
I was telling you right before we
started,
I just read the book,
so all of your thoughts in what's left
are there right at the tip of my brain
right now,
and I loved it.
I have been so in this regressive left
thing this far left that your whole,
your whole book is about and you saw it.
You saw it early.
So I want to get to that,
but before we start,
give me some of your liberal credentials
because I want people to know that
you're a lefty,
but because we're going to talk shit
about the left.
So I want people to know you're an
actual lefty,
Britain and Europe.
You wouldn't call me a liberal
socialist,
left
a way for whatever his problems and they
are manifest and man,
if bold,
because you didn't really cover it at
great length in America,
used to believe in things like tourism
and antique fascism in feminism to an
extent in being a part of the party of
progress.
And it used to have some idea of what to
do with the world.
And I gradually realized looking around
me,
but this was no longer the case that as
you like,
if you want to post it in sort of
really,
um,
a road rubbish terms really,
this know I didn't leave less,
less,
less meat,
less somebody's true,
but the,
the,
there was no longer a universal leftwing
mess with which meant that people around
the world could say,
look,
we're oppressed and we're oppressed by
heaviest reactionary forces.
The less wind resources.
So being in the UK,
I've had a bunch of my guests have been
lefties in the UK that are,
that are talking about the same issues
that you're talking about.
What is going on in the UK that I think
woke you guys up to this before it was
awoken in America?
Because really here,
it's only in the last year.
I think that that liberals are waking up
to what's going on on our side.
Yeah.
Whatever happens in America happens in
Brooklyn and your five years later for
one since the other way round,
I think that really big arguments and
big battles we've had in Brisbane in
particular all now coming to America,
you know,
the,
the Alice has been reversed the bit.
Um,
there has been the most,
uh,
for Roche rouse head,
which I'm pleased about because,
you know,
I'm a on polemicists system that Swiss
blendable I don't believe that the being
pc and nice and kind and gentle is a way
of sorting out problems is often a way
of covering them up.
But there have been huge rounds in
Britain,
uh,
really since nine slash 11 in my case,
since the Iraq war,
which mouse might seem rather wrong,
but,
uh,
your older may remember your faculty to
credit viewers may remember the won't
set on the saying was the enemy if left,
left wing is used to campaign in favor
of rights for the Kurds and pools have
damaged Sadam Hussein and fashion is.
So in my case,
it wasn't nine slash 11,
it was 2003 with the Iraq war.
And I says,
well,
thinking,
you know,
what happened to all my youth?
Why are,
why are you European?
Lester's food reason to,
you know,
help.
You never need a good reason to.
There are plenty of good reasons for
post George W Bush.
Um,
but,
um,
why,
why was it,
there was simply no concern for courage
in the Ra for socialist in the wrongful
trade unions from the rock who had been
until the late eighties.
Uh,
yeah,
that'd be demos to bound them.
That'd be petitioning to that support.
They've kind of at my parents home or
that kind of thing.
And you want to go,
well,
what happened there?
And once you start asking that question,
very simple question,
who are your friends who to use old left
wing Lang Lang,
joy,
your comrades,
uh,
who you sticking up for whatever kind of
Chris would you want to be of American
policy or public policy?
And our piece again,
opt for an interview.
There are always good grounds because of
American British policy who you actually
supporting.
And then you get some rather ugly
answers and you,
you find a source of great vacuum on or
most of the left and many good left wing
is on most of the left were a principal
ideology or to be.
Yeah.
So right there.
I mean you hit a lot of the books.
So a lot of the book deals directly with
Iraq and how it woke you up as you just
sat in the horrible things that Saddam
was doing and the horrible things that
the bath party was up to.
Um,
so before we get into that,
because I was actually surprised how
much of your journey was through Iraq.
But before we get into that,
specifically,
the phrase regressive left,
so it was coined by marginalized and
it's really,
it's really taken off here and end at
the beginning.
At the beginning of the book,
you mentioned that you didn't
necessarily have a word for this and you
said you didn't want to get too hung up
sort of onwards.
Do you like the phrase regressive left?
I'm sure there's something else.
Here's the thing,
a waltz graph came out in 2007.
I'm might go,
I'm,
I'm old.
No revolution like Kaboosh kids.
The reason I didn't,
I love the French progressive lesson is
absolutely right.
The reason why I didn't put a name to
it,
this,
you can say a very easy,
obviously it's just a fall next,
uh,
people who used to be Marxist,
Leninist,
trotskyists,
starbucks,
what have you.
But here's the problem.
When you interrogate these attitudes,
they go way,
way,
way into the mainstream.
It's people who don't consider
themselves less than at all.
I mean,
typically in Britain,
I'm sure this is true in America as
well,
from what I've seen,
it's people in broadcasting.
It's people in universities,
people in schools,
it's people in publishing.
It's people who are,
you know,
you had to define themselves and quite
favorable,
but then have a load of ideas,
a lot of baggage on them,
the terrible ideas we've started on the
far left and,
and this,
this is what grows people wilds in
Britain.
But this book was because I wasn't just
talking about how some people on the
friends and all sorts of talking about
people here in Britain will say,
BBC site people who never considered
himself extreme all with themselves,
models and new.
I'm not going to say,
well look,
these are ideas that began on the phone
and that it's okay to go along with
great dreams and movements that want to
subsidize the women kill.
Hadn't sexuals kill Jews,
kill any Muslim who have his or her own
free will decides to change their
religion.
There is no god,
there is no our tool.
You're getting along with all of this.
It wouldn't matter if it was gas six
grade,
what masters is permeating the whole
liberal,
um,
uh,
a spectrum.
And that's what growth people wild
available.
So to me that was so obviously true and
it seems to be true of as American as
well,
so you hit on a lot there.
So partly it seems to me that it's a
little bit like the phrase,
you know,
the road,
uh,
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions that these people,
and I think you hit on this advantage
that these people,
they have good intentions in that they
don't want extra war and we have had a
ridiculous,
both of our countries,
right?
You in the UK and in America we've had,
we have had plenty of ridiculous
unnecessary wars.
We've done all kinds of things,
drone strikes,
all of these things that we on the left
are not thrilled with,
but you make a really good argument for
what is the alternative that we
basically just give up on all of these
people that live under these horrible
theocracies.
And that's what put these people in the
far left in bed with some really
terrible people.
Yeah.
It's also a,
if you could get a time machine and go
into the future,
say 50 years into the future,
there are bound to be all kinds of ideas
are accepted.
The objects on the fringes of American
society at the moment.
Uh,
all your great panggang drums in the
media,
Time magazine,
New York Times barely even think about
will be the common sense.
Whatever age that applies to paddle
ideas as well as good ideas.
A really bad idea started on the far
left.
I would even say it wasn't even less
wind at all after the collapse of
communism,
after the end of socialist and members,
socialism defines what it means to be a
left winger for a hundred years.
You know,
some fruits are not,
they're not all girls.
Then somebody there,
all these people.
I mean,
noam is a classic example to me who have
that same spirit but no longer have an
ideology they can believe in.
And so what did they do?
They still just send anyone who is
against the West can't be all bad.
Anyone who is against the west,
it has to be the West fault.
We all the root cause to use a phrase
that's been repeated to and then you
suddenly find people who call themselves
radicals or progressive socialist
feminists going along with movements.
We anti progressive and she says,
Auntie radical anti women,
anti gay,
anti Semitic,
and she everything,
Auntie liberal in the classic sense
actually movements that have stepped out
for a liberal nightmare if you look at
their effects,
but because they're anti west,
that's all that matters is because
there's no longer a positive program
would be laughing.
They just seize on any body who is
against America,
again,
against to you Sarah rather contentious.
Then you can have an organist bath we
want later against imperialism,
and that that just stops on the
extremes.
Like good ideas start off on the fringes
and it comes into the main screen.
Now that's not wholly the faults.
Mainstream liberals,
senior,
never let drop your books off the whole.
Nevertheless,
Oralis is off the hook.
Yeah,
password is perfectly possible.
Action results.
So terrible and not just in,
you know,
poor countries.
Uh,
what about people in America?
What about,
um,
people in Britain?
What about people in my country,
Muslim women are now being told,
what are you going to go through a
course?
What is a free women in a free country,
not second class citizens,
so you don't have to have,
uh,
some,
fear classic legal system saying
evidence worth half that,
right?
But you as a white guy say that,
then people go bananas and you're
pushing your views on that even though
if you're the one that's abiding the
laws of your country,
which is what they are governed by.
Well now I'm afraid to lose my country
is slightly worse than that.
You know,
there's a danger.
We're not quite there yet.
We'll have parallel legal system will
have a say up in civil case,
divorce cases,
big deals.
Uh,
I'm a Muslim woman will,
uh,
seems quite content.
Say we can settle this to Shariyah cool,
but this is,
this is kind of racist.
Is it not?
If you say to a woman,
you have to go through a.
you're right.
All liberal opinion across Breslin,
across America,
across the world who go wild sexism.
New social needs is patreo police.
Okay.
When that happens to a brown skinned
woman,
yeah.
Were you in the name of liberalism?
We all,
we all create shaking the uh,
the classic double standards of,
of predictable days.
You know,
a white people have more rights and
white.
Certain people are more honest and brown
skinned people.
Kristen issue for how people are treated
in Saudi Arabia or Iran or,
or,
uh,
any other country with a uh,
um,
an for me,
I would say a unfair,
classic legal system.
It's here now.
I'm already societies.
It does seem to be the liberal soul to
decide what type of liberalism they
believe in July,
I believe in liberalism means we've got
equal rights and universal values or
does liberalism main.
There's one law for one group and one
law for another group depending on their
couch.
Does this part of this seem to you that
it's just the end game?
This is the end result of identity
politics.
We're,
we're going through right now in
America,
this really strong phase with identity
politics.
What?
Right.
So we're all divided on sexuality and
race and just every,
anything that you can divide people on
were divided on it right now and is part
of this just that you saw the end game
of all of this sorta before we did
your profit,
profit bibles or any of that.
To me,
there is a big,
big vacuum.
Opens up at the end of the 20th century
were first of all,
as I said before,
it may not be so much in America,
in Europe and the love of the world,
the collapse of socialism,
the collapse in the belief of off the
plan to call me of national society,
but all the sudden the clap,
so it kind of lung collapse,
but a marginalizing and flip real
optimism,
liberal locksmiths and just says,
look,
there were universal human rights.
It doesn't matter what your skin color
is,
you know,
it doesn't matter what your religion is.
You can't say,
oh,
it's my culture to oppress women.
You can't say that I was laughing.
You actually now like they laugh with
you and that's allowed.
It's identity politics,
which sounds fun.
Sounds Fun.
You know,
I ain't going to last,
you know,
I read these reports of black students.
So again,
when you think about history of a black
oppression in America and you can
understand them,
nesting is kid's sake a bit nuts by
identity politics has and you think,
well,
you know,
let them have their,
uh,
that fuss by identity.
Politics has a hugely dog.
So [inaudible] you have no onset.
We're in the people who say we're the
masters,
we are against identity.
We all the community leaders,
we all the mothers will a rabbi's
priests.
We control this group,
this block and we say you were a part of
our group or block or community and uh,
we,
we say that you didn't have the same
bright.
So it's a,
you know,
a white Anglo Saxon woman at Yale.
We say the constitution,
the bill of rights doesn't apply to you.
It's against your culture.
And that hasn't been thought through at
all.
Right?
So we split people into,
into these little boxes.
But then what we ended up carrying the
least about is the people that are in
the smaller boxes within those boxes.
Well,
as monitoring the wall set,
so you mentioned doing it view has this
little phrase,
what about minorities?
We remind ourselves,
you know,
what about what about liberals and this
is thinkers,
the blast females,
the women,
the gay.
So people who say,
what the hell,
what the hell?
I am not this group.
I'm not a Muslim or a Jew or whatever.
I'm American.
Right?
That to me is the
ultimate irony here is that the spectrum
of people that I've brought on the show
in that now I've connected with on
twitter or wherever it is,
is I'm not judging any of these people
based on their color or their religion
or their ethnicity.
I'm basing it on their ideas,
which is,
which is the most liberal idea.
Yeah.
Well,
you're actually treating them as
individuals because they're very,
very different.
Uh,
a golf help you.
The only problem of identity politics is
when you stop preaching to people as
individuals.
You kind of identity politics is,
is,
uh,
is a,
is a slippery,
treacherous conjunction is you can only
have like,
or you can have politics.
Politics means you don't just look at
people and say,
there's a block in this instance,
what we're talking about,
the Muslims,
what do you mean there's a group called
the Muslims because when do you say that
you normally end up handing over the
right to speak to these Muslims who have
asked your permission to the most
reactionary people in it.
The people who who,
who wants to enforce a communal identity
and want to enforce it.
First of all,
you know,
I know there's all this paranoia going
round after the Paris attacks and those
awful events in California,
but yeah,
first and foremost want to enforce on
Barrow,
unkind on their tribe in fourth or fifth
of booze on them to keep them down.
And the worst part of it is,
I think we've been particularly bad in
Britain and America because we have this
identity politics.
Multicultural problem you've had is,
well,
you know what?
I'm about the men and the women who say,
I'm the second.
This guy said,
the community leader doesn't represent
me.
I've never voted for him and agree with
him.
What about this man who says he's a
priest?
The rabbi and Lula,
I can't believe in all this crap or I'd
be partially believe in it or I believe
in bits to this,
but you,
you then stopped treating me as if this
guy and this meeting is,
this group owns me without my permission
that that's his.
That's his huge weakness today.
It's well an awful lot.
Before we go onto great question,
so with the sound,
with your right,
with Syria,
you know,
what are you going to do about Islamic
state is where everyday cruelty happens
in also song.
That's it.
It's where men and women who need a
confident liberalism and liberalism
beliefs in human rights,
liberalism that says,
well actually we're not going to say
that.
What matters first and foremost about
you is your color or creed.
They need them to help them and they
turned around to the very people who
will be able to help them and they're
not there.
In fact,
they're on the other side.
That's,
that's the key piece because it's not
just that it's there.
They're actually working to stop the
reformers and by calling everyone racist
and all of this stuff,
and then you know what we have going on
very much so in America right now is
that Donald trump just this week says,
we're going to close the borders to all
Muslims.
Well,
now he throws red meat to the right.
He gets.
He probably does more good work for isis
recruiting that he could possibly do,
but unfortunately he's been strengthened
by by a week left.
You talk a lot about that actually,
about how they the this far left group.
Now what we're calling the regressives
ultimately end up strengthening a lot of
ideas that they should be against.
That's what we're seeing with trump.
I was amazing today in which is where I
work and I loved the place and here's
Britain's leading left,
the newspaper and people in your
questions about Donald Trump.
That first questions were know and you
could see perhaps I'm reading too much
into the audience members and such,
but Donald Trump was stopping her.
She taking on reaction.
Whereas in,
you know,
all on years,
on years besides so you,
you've gone.
It's very hard to,
uh,
to get the notion that there are two
extreme rights,
there is the extreme right,
and I wouldn't until a few weeks ago
said Donald Trump was on it.
It seems to be heading that way now and
there is the religious extreme,
right,
extreme,
uh,
and you need to find them both for the
same reasons and with the same
arguments.
She's very different.
People seem to find that very,
very difficult to do.
Strikes me as the only principal
position,
but I imagined if I walked onto any
campus in America and said that there'll
be no platform,
not only would there be no platform,
but they'd be trigger warning.
Do they go into a safe space?
All the other stuff we're talking about
it.
And then
was so frightening.
Right?
I've had several guests that I didn't
think were that frightening,
that for some reason have to have
trigger warnings issued before they
speak on campuses.
So a look,
a lot of this is happening in Europe
first,
which is another reason that I'm talking
about it so much because I don't want it
to take hold here the way it has taken
hold in Europe.
What do you make of the far right
parties that are now winning across
Europe?
Right?
Marine Le Pen.
Just one in France.
We're in.
I now see that in Denmark and in Sweden
far right.
Parties are leading in polls for the
first time ever.
Belgium.
Uh,
so this thing seems to be miss
metastasizing,
uh,
right in front of our eyes.
Yeah,
there are reasons for that day.
I mean the European Union.
It's not like USA.
You're trying to beeline the USA without
the common culture,
common institutions.
And as I'm fond of pointing out to a,
uh,
a in new world to be like the US.
So I said,
well,
USA had one hell of a civil war before
it became the USA Today.
I mean,
do you want,
do you want that?
There are other reasons.
A,
there's two things I want to say.
One you might quite like the other than
think you might quite like is,
is we seem to agree on this.
It says you can't run around the streets
in your head off A.
Yeah.
Having trigger warnings and safe spaces
where I'd know a celebrity or a
politician makes a slightly off color
remark about homosexuals or women who's
like sexist remark about women and
having reading the news and a couple of
times,
um,
uh,
needing,
needing a culture to calm themselves
down afterwards and then,
and then ignore religious homophobia,
including beverly religious,
Saturday,
February among ethnic minorities.
You can't do that without paying a price
because I think people aren't watching
you,
you know,
don't think the rest of society had lots
of political writing on the left as well
as the right.
It's like it's a private club,
you know,
it's talk to themselves,
but yeah,
the right watches,
Fox News,
sort of less walk.
She's Gong Stewart,
you know,
they just talk themselves.
So it's like a private club and everyone
understands the rules and they forget
the sound side.
It's a watchman and get outside and are
say,
you bloody hypocrites.
You,
you,
you will,
you will have one rule for white people
and another rule for the rest and you
will not stand up to get back.
And as principal,
so there is that,
that does matter.
A political correctness in Britain has
become,
has become this kind of swear words and
it doesn't mean stuff that you would
understand.
My political rights means deep,
deep,
deep hypocrisy.
Ms Dot government too.
Government.
So that's all true.
You can blame the left only on hands.
You know people about how bad am I
allowed to swear on your progress?
Where away bring it people who voted for
Donald Trump.
There has to come a point where you just
say,
well,
fuck off.
If you're voting for Donald Trump,
you have a greater pet.
We moved Sean.
We will not,
we will not give up on you with your
fellow citizens.
But there comes a point where you said,
well,
to hell with you,
you know,
you are peddling.
The difficulty is,
and is.
It does come.
I can't.
If you're very confused about this,
we've now go the worst type of,
uh,
of leftist leading or opposition parties
later who's like a caricature.
If I had to write an example of,
of the worst of the leftists and
Britain,
Jeremy Corbyn,
Jeremy,
yeah.
The only good thing about them becoming
a believer,
his books I wrote are now selling like
hotcakes,
but I mean by selfish point of view of
science is,
is you've got a terrible rights in
America with trump in France who's
national front in Sweden and Denmark and
all these places a pendulum and,
and he's popping all over your,
no interest because immigration
integration,
Paul,
because the European,
a single currency as being one of the
greatest economic mistakes.
Um,
and then you go left in a space where a
principal should be certainly embracing.
You've got this kind of geographical,
a good girl.
I'm with,
um,
uh,
any organization,
how as a fascistic uh,
as long as it sound.
So you didn't who?
Lots of people who are feeling a bit
political politically homeless over
here.
Yeah.
Does it all feel like a perfect storm to
you?
What's going on right now,
and again this,
this is the stuff that's after your book
when we talk about the refugees and some
of the economic problems in Europe and
this,
you know,
dealing with radical Islam.
It was going on while you were writing
the book obviously,
but it seems,
it seems to me we have like five things
right now that are all working at the
same time.
Then you toss in social media,
you toss in that.
We see videos from everywhere now we
see,
we can see beheadings,
we can see bombing,
you know,
so you can see,
you can see religious violence and you
can see state violence all the time that
we really have all of this happening at
once and it's leading to a,
to a very strange place.
I think one thing Dave,
we can say with certainty that whoever
it was a full of Berlin Wall was the end
of history history.
If over boy was that a stupid thing to
say and you can't,
you can't.
Let me get back to the point I made.
She was stopped at the weirdness and
hypocrisy and the awful betrayal of
people you get on.
People who call themselves the left
comes,
were like,
don't have a socialist alternative you
like to have in the Soviet Union falls.
Socialism collapses across the world.
No one believes that anymore.
And that,
that was fine for awhile.
If I may generalize it a very Glib way,
uh,
that was fine for awhile because
capitalist,
and we'll call it what you will,
seems to be a great success story,
seemed to work.
That's why I it for Carolina was not an
idiot when he said,
well,
ever since the crash of 2008,
that system of liberal capitalism has
failed.
And that's why you've got this feeling
of perfect storm.
Too many things coming,
as I said,
what is it is not entirely.
There's a wonderful phrase by the
Italian socialists,
Antonio Gramsci,
you own despair.
The new cannot be born in that
interregnum.
Many strange,
strange forms will appear.
It seems like that we don't know what
comes next.
We're not sure of what we've got.
We're not sure it works anymore.
I'm not sure it works,
so yeah,
or Ms Dot middle class America.
Americans watching your program have
their payers and going after the super
rich are getting richer.
The American dream doesn't seem to quite
work anymore.
Even with it with a bomber.
Listen,
not quite clear where.
Where are the old challenges for that?
Aren't you get these strange boredom's a
free case forms,
which is when I wrote about cork.
Yeah.
As I said,
people just kept saying for your neck,
neck,
neck that suggest they suggest on the
friendlies.
Well now it's on the main screen.
Going to that point.
What about some of the tactics these
guys use and I want to talk a little bit
about Chomsky,
but first we can talk just sort of in
the more broader sense.
When I've seen the way these guys debate
or the way they treat topics and you
know,
again,
everyone is racist and all that.
They don't seem to mind if they get
caught in lies.
They don't.
They love just throwing out the bomb and
then we let it spreads like wildfire on
social media and you know,
there's that famous saying,
you know,
it takes one second to lie,
but it takes a lifetime to get it back
or whatever.
And it seems that a series of these
guys,
they love this and I don't know,
look again,
I'm not on the right so I can't really.
I don't like the right.
I've never been part of the right.
So I police them differently,
but I don't want to see this from my
guys.
So what do you think about just the
tactics that they're using?
One question to you,
a plain speaking,
open heart.
It doesn't behave.
Any bathroom that people
look,
they don't look,
I'm,
look,
I'm dealing in America with trump right
this second with over the top bombast
city.
So,
and again this is why.
Look I'm a guilty liberal in that sense
that sometimes I feel bad.
I spent so much time on the guys on my
side and then I'm afraid,
you know,
people ask me all the time,
am I afraid that ultimately this will
strengthen the right?
But I,
but to me it's like,
if we don't stand up now,
well then the game is over.
We just hand it to the right,
which is what's happening.
I think with trump.
Uh,
well,
um,
there is a long tradition of,
of,
of lying on the left,
you know,
if you go back to,
to Stalin,
he,
he golfs gullible people to believe in
show trials where people confess the
croc impossible crimes that were
committed.
So there is bad.
I'm less,
I'm less interested unless concerned
about left and right.
Then this,
here is something that happens when with
new media,
you know,
have stapes,
uh,
here for two years,
I think is a pretty bad thing.
Uh,
I think his main audience seems to be
little girl,
and this could be reusing material to
write,
but you know,
uh,
it's,
you know,
it's a bad day.
You've got nothing to do.
You got no ideas.
I know I'll turn on Fox News is,
is we're pretty lucky.
You've now got states,
Russia and Iran most notionally
producing propagate the gamble.
So beggar cater to pushing whole truth,
conspiracy theories,
lies,
you know,
gets shot down over Ukraine.
There's television channels in English
who are pumping stuff out.
So you were around as wants,
if you're on the left in America,
you just have to go on and on about
something.
Nixon was posting downs or something in
the Wall Street Journal reading
something on Fox News.
And if you're only in America,
you were complaining about New York
Times,
you know,
deliberately covering something up.
Now you suddenly go whole states,
uh,
with their secret services at foreign
offices that propaganda arms behind him
pumping material include west,
which is instantly taken up by both the
far left on the roads case.
It's very difficult certainly in
Britain.
So as I say,
things have gotten much much earlier
than they have in America is very,
very difficult to tell her.
Um,
uh,
the people who support boosting,
for instance,
in Russia today,
you've got marine Le Pen doing it.
Who is the lead for French far right
party.
You Got Galloway gallaway who's just
screening as combination of left
business.
And Mr Griffin,
I mean,
and so you've got a kind of merger of
the extremes against liberal democracy
and they're both equally Kim Kardashian
that both equally sinful nature raw.
What matters to the most is,
is building conspiratorial narrative.
So in a lot of ways we really could
blame sort of mainstream media for this
craziness,
right?
Because it seems to me that for a long
time,
mainstream media,
which had no competition before the
digital age,
they did such a poor job that then they
handed everything over to the digital
side and I think for awhile the online
media for the first few years of it,
I think they did do a really nice job in
breaking stories and getting out
information that you wouldn't,
that you wouldn't get otherwise.
And now it seems like the gloves are off
and now it's,
anything's true.
Nobody knows who to trust.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
But there's a lot of truth now except
some kind of binary division between new
major in Obj.
It's good journalists and it's a
problem.
Dave,
if you are me to go and observe a or a
on the time,
do you,
you're talking reports on the La Times a
and something that you've done a
terrible job of.
You're allowing all these,
a crank.
These fruitcakes sees a Flim,
flam merchants from all over the world
or to walk all over you.
The man or woman the La Times was,
it looked like,
oh,
business models collapsed.
You know,
we're trying to staff your rows and in
Peking and Beijing and you know,
give me a break.
Yeah,
we can.
We can.
We can barely get a report or you know,
up the road,
San Francisco,
the business model for if you like
serious,
a serious farmer,
as good as it is,
getting harder and harder,
sustainable.
Surely La Times and newspapers and
across America are to my knowledge from
having met him and we work on them.
I'll to try and keep it going.
But Indian,
the lack of money talks,
money talks.
That's the silence that comes from the
lack of money is a silence between.
Yes,
yes.
This debate,
so the gap is being filled and what
worries me is it's not people talking
rubbish or people talking drivel is they
always have is where are you going to
get the reliable report?
So what is happening in Peking,
Beijing?
Where are you going to get the reliable
pull reports on how coaching is
manipulating a European opinion that's
getting harder and harder to.
Okay.
Well,
as it,
as someone that I consider an expert in
this space,
how do you decide who to trust?
I,
I really don't know anymore.
you know,
I follow a lot of different
organizations,
right?
Left middle,
know as reputable and some off the deep
end and I try to pilfer out some
knowledge and some truth and I try not
to only follow things that reinforce my
beliefs,
which is another huge problem with
social media has given us.
But how do you decide who to trust?
Well,
you probably got accused me of being
horribly old fashioned stuff,
but I mean there are student
organizations I trust,
you know,
um,
I still trusted off trying to newspapers
and Alexis because I know there's a
very,
very strong editing process there and
it's opinion pages are sap for us and
what have you.
Now that may changes as the business
model for journalism goes down,
but I still don't.
Well,
look,
they had an op Ed on the front page for
the first time in [inaudible] 95 years.
Just disgraceful.
Disgraceful.
Yeah.
Let's go around the wheels,
go round and have a dinner.
So we don't want your bloody opinions.
We also say,
give us some news.
I've read a paper that had that on the,
on the front of.
All right,
so let,
let's back up for a second.
Let's talk for a few minutes about Noam
Chomsky because you talk about him a bit
in the book.
It's not a tremendous amount but you.
But I have a friend,
uh,
who is on what I consider it in this
regressive group.
And a lot of times we'll be debating
back and forth about this stuff and
I'll,
I'll be giving him as much historical
knowledge as I have and as much factual
knowledge as I have.
And then he'll sort of always end
everything by saying,
well,
I don't really know about that,
but I read some Chomsky and I'm just
kind of giving back to you.
And I think you sort of hit on that also
in the book that there's just this
belief in this guy that maybe isn't
fully warranted or he's been.
He's been very good at waving off the
things that don't quite agree with his
worldview.
It's interesting for two reasons.
I mean,
he was an old guy.
Come on,
shout them down.
But I mean he's adopted some pretty
disgraceful positions,
a massive Bosnian Muslims.
And so going along with people who are
1990 and going along and never missing
is wrong.
And building this very.
Trump's,
his writing is very poor writing,
so stands for English,
but it builds is very dense web of
light.
Your friend wants your in your like,
uh,
a fly in the.
Whether it's very to go out,
so that's.
That's kind of a a fishing.
You say in America,
you finished this man.
This is.
This is all from a point of view.
It sort of made up and actually when you
figured out what he's doing is quite
disgraceful,
but here's why Chomsky was worth
diversion.
Chapter two is it is what kinds of.
You are young on an American campus and
you get your.
Can you read all his books and you
think,
well,
what kind of society are you aiming for?
There is no social vision.
There's nothing that the grasses and
socialists to run through American
history from the 18 eighties were
recognized.
So just say,
this is all just saying Americans,
shit me,
me,
shit,
America.
We probably would never have happened.
The pilgrim files,
we probably have churned down at
Plymouth Rock and gone back to England.
The whole thing is a disaster.
Everything it does is wrong.
The thing is alive and you think,
well actually ridiculous World Vision,
funnily enough.
Here's the thing.
It's really easy to buy into because you
didn't have to commit to anything if the
regressive left.
And so I really liked that phrase,
well,
let's take the regressive left.
Skin left the post socialist left.
On the one hand it has very little to
say positive and that's,
that's kind of easy for everyone to sign
up to.
You just have to think that Washington
is a pile of shit.
But I mean Washington DC is a pile of
shit.
Well that's sure as you know,
the State Department doesn't have,
is doing fine.
The CIO is wicked.
And so instead of having a left wing,
you had to make really positive
commitments for,
you know,
40 years ago I couldn't have come on
your program and said,
I'm a socialist,
right?
I'm a socialist.
I.
And you're already said,
oh nick,
he's associate if that sounds good,
we'll go along and I say I wasn't
massively high taxes or I want to
nationalize this and that.
And people who would it be an agreement?
We said we'll back off and say,
hell,
I don't want anything to do with this.
You know,
this guy is threatening my Livingston.
Now you just have to say that,
uh,
everything you read is ally,
your government's evil unless been,
unfortunately,
that's actually because the flaking,
so few positive policy commitments as
Chomsky does.
It's certainly very easy to go along
with him.
You know,
I get into the hands of people here in
London,
which is a very expensive city for the
rich people I know.
And that books find them Chomsky on the,
on the,
uh,
on their shelves.
And that's big because funnily enough
rules,
suppose radicalism that kind of left
without a positive program with just the
critique is no threat to them.
It's no fretful wealthy.
He's known knowing fractally pamphlets.
They were friendly bankers on Wall
Street.
You know,
it's something.
Lots of people when they quite
justifiably often pissed off at
government or because you know,
they,
they've got a conspiracy theory mind
though because they will look friendly.
Everyone can sign up to that January
left wing program is hard.
The genuine left wing program make
friends and enemies,
but this kind of pseudo life,
this regressive left.
It's terribly easy,
easily even too easy I think for any
successful political movement.
You know,
it's interesting because I was really
embedded in it for a couple of years and
I guess I hadn't pieced this all
together what you're talking about,
but right now,
but part of my frustration was that we
never talked about solutions.
We always could talk about problems,
right?
It was always,
you know,
the American industrial complex and and
bombing and race and whatever,
but there were never solution so that,
that does get to what you're saying that
it's
could as soon as you offer solution,
you're going to piss some people off
because it's an illusion meat and you're
not making a commitment.
And as soon as you make a commitment,
a little Dave Rubin believed this,
well,
it's just wrong.
It's very easy to just say it's all a
conspiracy it so that way you don't
expose yourself.
You're not making.
You're not making a poster program and
sticking your neck out there where you
sit down.
So speaking of conspiracy theories,
one of the through lines throughout the
book,
and then you do devote a chapter to it
in completion,
is that in all of these movements,
somehow blaming the Jews are always.
It always comes around to blaming the
Jews.
Now the language has changed.
Now it's blaming.
Zionists
blamed.
No one says to us anymore
right now,
right?
It's not,
it's not politically correct to say
Jews.
So you just say Zionists are you say
Israel or whatever it is,
but you really did lay out an
interesting piece in almost every
example throughout time that they were
always blame on both sides.
They,
the capitalists would say the Jews are
socialists.
Socialists would say Jews are
capitalists and every other which way.
What do you think that is about?
I think you probably just explained it
with this conspiratorial thing and the
other.
Yeah.
Well,
look,
here's the problem.
If you genuinely,
you will see I have a person for many,
many folks and I'm sure they'll lesion,
but if you genuinely think that they,
for instance,
secretly blew up the twin towers,
uh,
and then,
then all kinds of types of play the
adventures away if you go into a or a
bomber is replies to the,
as much less.
A borrower isn't to real American.
He's a secret Muslim from Kenya.
You know,
if you can even believe that you have to
believe in extraordinary view of the
world where a handful of people can fool
the entire population.
The sheep poop.
Well,
while she's thinking about who are those
handful of people historically,
you know,
you started down that road,
you ended up the grades.
Well,
how have you found shocking being called
caring?
Yeah.
And I think some of a liberal American
Jews will find it shocking because I say
we're five years ahead of you.
Uh,
when it comes and hits her,
is this I how I never expected to find
out a few sentences perhaps I was being
like and um,
but it is quite extraordinary,
uh,
the extent of it.
And it's quite extraordinary how it's
tolerated now,
isn't cooldowns now?
So do you think some of that when,
when I hear people say that the first
real quick we should mention.
So you just mentioned your last name
calling.
You're actually not Jewish.
my family abandoned her religion for
Regina was system.
So,
you know,
I'm,
I'm going to ask Tommy and his family
have about 1900 views.
Wouldn't have to pay strict.
And Dave,
it's not.
Yeah,
we'll be able to finger cute little said
you were curious.
But here's the problem.
If you look at Anti Semitism,
antisemitism has virtually nothing to do
with you.
Antisemitism became in the late 19th
century,
early 20th century.
And the Nazis,
it was some way of fighting progress.
It was a way of saying,
look,
you democracy,
human rights,
women's rights,
all these,
you shouldn't believe in them.
They were all praying.
So fraud,
say as a,
uh,
they will,
behind them is a pipe master,
pulling the strings in that public mass
with acute.
Um,
so you,
you would afford,
there's a left,
but believes in democracy and human
rights will be for its own sake because
maps,
anything else only alert the whole time
for the dangers of.
But actually,
you know,
going back to trump's aid believes the
box.
They believe human rights is all full.
They believe it's all live.
So that's one reason why they ended up
doing or not Chomsky himself,
but that's why people end up there and
they don't understand what goes with it.
They didn't look at organizations like
Hezbollah or Iran or and say,
hold on a second,
okay,
they're antisemitic,
but that's just because of Israel.
And then they say,
well,
homesick,
but look,
the way they women look at where they
treat rules,
look at the way that they just miss
human rights were dismissed.
Democracy in antisemitism absolutely
goes along with that.
And once you accept antisemitism,
you have to not just anti racist,
but you have all your progressive
principles because historically,
antisemitism has always been used by
Oprah reactory movement who again left
should be against.
Right?
So this,
I always say when it comes to this,
and I was just in Israel last week and
at the top of the show when I,
when I did my,
my piece,
I was saying how I saw coexistence
there.
I was in Jerusalem,
you know,
I ate falafel in the Arab quarter,
saw Israeli policemen helping Muslim
women move a box.
I saw ultra orthodox Jews.
I mean,
that doesn't happen anywhere in the
Mideast except for Israel.
And of course not to say everything's
perfect there and there's all sorts of
political problems,
religious problems and all that,
but that doesn't.
But the only place that has any
progressive values in the Middle East is
Israel.
And they,
uh,
I walked about quarter the boundary on
the wrong too.
You know,
you say someone says,
well,
as problems on the West Bank,
there's problems in gauze.
And you said what about Syria?
Because actually is quite a good wall.
So that the council was about,
when you think about it,
um,
but you know,
you shouldn't say that doesn't mean that
students shouldn't have to run the state
and doesn't mean no horrendous problems
with the Israeli rocked and you
shouldn't sort of romanticize Israel.
I'm a asshole.
Um,
but,
but yeah,
but here's the thing is the problem.
The problem is,
is this is great reasons for,
I would say the liberal liberal
difficulty understanding radical Islam
is.
There's very good liberal impulse to
assumes the world is rational.
You know,
there's the assumes that if there is,
it's terrible.
Terroristic movement that were blow out
of the twin towers,
the woods.
And we knew if they had chemical weapons
or nuclear weapons against feeling say
words.
That must be a root cause for it.
You know,
that must be some rational explanation
that we can satisfy that we can operate
these evil goals.
I'm thinking they call just be that
angry again and stuff is not partly our
fault.
Yeah.
I saw,
I saw a lot of that actually right after
the Paris attacks because I saw
immediately my friends on the left
saying American foreign policy,
American foreign policy,
even though two days later,
you know,
Boko Haram killed 140 people and
obviously that has nothing to do with
foreign policy,
but.
But there's this rationalization even
though at the same time the people who
did the Paris attacks were saying this
is for religious purposes.
Yeah.
But your friends on the left,
your source gallery,
the history of narcissism,
of the history of communism.
Yes.
There are rational reasons.
So you can blame,
you know,
you could say if,
if,
um,
yeah,
bombs go off and actually had an office
in Paris,
you're friends will have said,
oh,
it's their fault.
They,
the peanuts cartoon and Mohamad people
slaughtered a,
I think every supermarket in Paris,
the hypogastric Oh,
it's their fault.
Uh,
because of Israel,
because Israel is occupying the West
Bank.
So okay,
you killed us service.
That's okay.
You kill the cues that say people who
are or to,
if it's a football stadium started the
parents,
people who are slow to a rock concert,
people are sources of Cambodian
restaurants on the Parisians well that's
coming is their fault because we're not
quite sure American foreign policy be
friends for on policy.
Now.
These all sorts of rational explanations
and there's a bit of true freedom.
The problem is every step you change
seems rational and liberal,
but every step you take takes you away
from rationality and liberalism and you
ran into.
They're very murderous.
You're trying to explain because you
accepted that whole ideology,
but rather turn the standards.
You don't understand it.
They are not people who are sitting
there saying,
well,
we've got a rational grievance like
someone's about to file a claim to as a
county.
Cool.
They have a youtube channel is having an
ideology.
You go and live freely 20 to central,
a last bit of the 20th century,
20th century when you in ideologies to
millions of millions of people.
We still don't understand that.
Someone like Islamic state says,
we think we can create heaven on earth
week,
think we can a caliphate that will
govern the holder and this will be
paradox.
And you do that.
What's a matter of 1 million,
2 million,
10 million people are killed.
They don't,
you,
they think they're explained.
They don't understand anything.
Yeah.
So that actually is the ultimate irony
because on one hand you're saying,
well,
look,
if we took everything,
if we did whatever it is they want us to
do,
right?
We took all our troops out of here,
we stopped bombing here,
whatever.
Then suddenly they,
they'd like us more,
but that's not what they're saying.
So it really is.
It's the most ironic a piece
they want you to do,
Dave,
is becoming,
then yes.
I'm.
So here you go.
I mean,
your friends are in California and
probably,
you know,
I'm,
I'm sure they're lovely people.
So some of them,
um,
but,
you know,
I'm sure they think of themselves as
down to you sexist and racist,
uh,
until you have a phobic.
I'm sure they're fine on trans issues,
you know,
I bet some of them don't even get me,
but they will then through thinking that
being logical end up defending the most
sexist,
racist,
homophobic in liberal movements on the
and you certainly the point made by me,
it was a very brilliant French
philosopher.
Usually they're very narcissistic way,
you know,
we all.
Central is the world,
you know,
if something terrible happens,
it must be down to us.
Know the people in the rest of the world
have their own agency,
not people in the rest of the world.
Cup I guess is wicked little as well.
You can say our infant say are children
who are goaded by us.
It's all down to what we do.
We are still.
Yeah,
the narcissist ego,
the people,
the people that sent for before.
Yeah.
I think what I had done with and he
illustrated that point,
he said,
look,
the world could go to hell in a
handbasket and it'll have nothing to do
with America.
You just can't.
It's just child.
It's childlike thinking of.
Yeah.
All right,
so increasing steadily treats Muslim
populations as children isn't.
Yeah,
I mean it says,
he says,
look,
we're adults.
We're wearing these white western
Europeans.
Yeah,
we can handle satire.
We can handle all leaders and Godson,
bishops,
clerics.
Oh my God,
you can't do those Muslims like
toddlers.
You're like violent little delinquent
children.
You've shown them a cartoon and they
start blowing the place up.
Yeah.
Ironically,
that's what George W dot Bush called the
soft bigotry of low expectations,
which I keep crediting Bill Maher with.
But apparently it was George W Bush,
which is mind blowing.
That's is a very,
very good for.
And it's true actually.
It's worse than the soft bigotry.
Uh,
it does keep people down because look,
most of the men and women watching your
program in California doesn't really
help them when they're going out looking
for a job,
uh,
or,
you know,
looking to get on in life or wanting to
create respect.
We want to be crazy recalls if liberals
all saying,
oh,
well,
you know,
that's very,
very funny people,
these people,
you have to be very careful what you say
in French car tuned up,
blow the top of my head.
It doesn't help them.
It doesn't help them be full citizens to
increase in a totally different way from
everyone else.
Yeah,
absolutely.
All right,
so I have one more for Ya.
I could do this for five hours with you,
so you'll have to.
You'll have to come on again.
I want you to have your tea and go to
bed.
So I'll end with this.
Look,
you wrote what's left in 2007.
Uh,
that was eight years ago.
So let's fast forward eight years from
now.
It's 20,
23.
Give me a little hope if you can find
some hope,
but if you can't then give me where you
think we're going to be at eight years
from now.
Well,
that was,
that was quite hopeful.
I'm working on.
I wrote that lesson.
I hope it will run ally on a liberal
intellectuals,
feminists,
uh,
within the Muslim world.
Uh,
we're in Muslim communities in the west
taking on various treatments.
I just hope that shame,
which has descended on Western
liberalism,
it's almost shameful periods of history
that when those liberals and Democrats
and those feminist take home,
they're extremist fucking western
liberals.
They're meant to do.
And support them instead of supposedly
they are in the mess to make any excuses
for that randomness for once lives,
their principals or otherwise they'll
just give up,
get up,
shut up.
Say actually we don't really talk.
We just want to go to the beach,
have a beer,
dental care and we didn't really care
about other people but either
give up or show some solidarity.
I love that.
And I do like a well placed fuck.
So that was a,
that was really nice to uh,
you guys can pick up either of nick's
books,
wherever books are sold or you can
download an ebook however you do that.
I did it so you can probably figure it
out.
Uh,
nick,
it was really,
it was an absolute pleasure.
I hope we can do this in La,
uh,
in,
in person next time.
And I thank you guys for watching and
we'll do it again next week.